كانت مسيرته مع يونايتد في ازدهار وبفضل
ادائه الاستثنائي في موسم 2007 2008 فاز
رونالدو بجائزه الكره الذهبيه الاولى
ليصنف اخيرا كافضل لاعب في العالم
لكن في صدى فوزه بجائزه الكره الذهبيه
والعيبه المذهل في الملعب بدات الشائعه
تنتشر في خصوص رغبه رونالدو بالانتقال من
النادي اعلن ان نادي مانشستر سيتي الذي
كان تحت ملكيه جديده حينها يسعى الى شرائه
المال ليس معضله بالنسبه اليكم ماذا ان
اصبح رونالدو متاحا فهو يلعب حاليا مع
اكبر منافسيكم مانشستر يونايتد هل ستدفعون
70 او 80 او 100 مليون جنيه استرليني
مقابل سيتخذ هذا القرار بالاشتراك مع مدير
النادي مارك هيوز اذا اراد مدير النادي دم
رونالدو الى مانشستر سيتي
سنؤمن التمويل بين اسهم راس المال والفرق
هل ستدفعون 60 او 70 مليون جنيه استرليني
مقابل يعتمد الامر على استحقاقه للمبلغ
اذا كان يستحق سندفع لكن نفر رونالدو هذه
الشائعه سريعا حيث صرح انه لن يغادر ناديه
السؤال الاخير لي هل ستبقى مع مانشستر
يونايتد ام ان الشائعات عن مغازاتك
الصحيحه في اعتقادك من سيلعب مع فريق
مدريد العام المقبل
ثم تحمق في هذا المكان اليس كذلك ظنتك قلت
متى كانوا في ناديه
ان اردتني ان اراهن على ذلك ساراهن جدا
على نفسي واعتقد انه اذا كان اللاعب
سيغادر اولد ترافورد ويغادر مانشستر واراد
الذهاب الى نادي افضل وهذا قابل للجدال
تمت خيار واحد وهو ريال مدريد وكان ذلك
مغريا جدا لدرجه ان رونالدو كان مهتما
بذلك رامون كالديرون سعيت بشده للحصول على
رونالدو وتقول انك لم تعد تسعى للتوقيع
معها هل تطمئن مشجعي مانشستر يونايتد انك
لن تسعى للحصول عليه عندما يفتح باب
الانتقال من جديد لا قلت ان كريستيانو
رونالدو قرر البقاء مع مانشستر يونايتد
وقرر ليونايتد الا يبيع اللاعب وهذا كل
شيء لا يمكننا فعل اي شيء في خصوص ذلك
هذا يحصل مع لاعبين ايضا ترغب نوادر اخرى
بالحصول على العديد من لاعبينا لكن يغلق
النقاش في حال لم يريدوا المغادره ولما
نرد البيع لم تعد تريد الحصول عليه اذا
نحن نرغب بالحصول على اي لاعب بارع في
العالم مثل ما يرغب مانشستر بالحصول على
اي لاعب بارع ليس فقط من ريال مدريد بل من
جميع ارجاء العالم ايضا لكن اعتقد ان
الاتفاق يجب ان يتم بين النادي واللاعب في
العام 2019 تحولت الشائعات الى حقيقه تم
الاتفاق على نقل رونالدو الى ريال مدريد
مقابل مبلغ كليا قدره 80 مليون جنيه
استرليني ليصبح حينها اغلى لاعبا تم شرائه
في تاريخ كره القدم تصدر الانتقال
العناوين في العالم وبدا رونالدو سعيدا
ومتحمسا لللعب مع الفريق الحاصل على 31
لقبا للدوري الاسباني واحد اثنان ثلاثه
مرحبا مدريد